è venuto a mancare è tornato
alla casa
padre cia frena mentre
spirava serenamente si è spenta potrei
continuare l'elenco molto a lungo ma è
chiaro il punto è che facciamo di tutto
pur di non dire è morta o è morto
non vogliamo in nessuna occasione
parlare di morte ed è anche chiaro la
ragione per cui non vogliamo farla ma a
volte diventa rischioso diventa
rischioso perché facilitiamo le
disuguaglianze e le discriminazioni è
mancato all'affetto dei suoi cari forse
uno dei più dei modi di dire più usati e
se n'è andato il più equivoco non solo
nei necrologi perché necrologi non
rischiamo di non capire che stiamo
parlando di una morte ma in tutte le
nostre conversazioni nei titoli dei
giornali negli anniversari come dicevo è
chiaro il motivo per cui non vogliamo
parlare di morte spesso anche tra adulti
abbiamo la tendenza a pensare anche che
sia qualcosa che porta male
non è raro vedere gesti quasi di insomma
tra corn e altre altre forme in cui si
vuole allontanare questo pensiero però
come vi dicevo se ne parliamo
non possiamo evitare di morire
naturalmente ma se ne parliamo possiamo
provare a decidere come non sempre
naturalmente perché ci sono casi di
incidenti e morti improvvise ma in tutte
quelle condizioni in cui c'è una
malattia cronica una malattia che si
prolunga quindi una condizione malattia
terminale
possiamo almeno decidere come possiamo
decidere di non soffrire per esempio
possiamo decidere di non prolungare una
condizione che è veramente una
sopravvivenza possiamo decidere perché
la decisione medica
tutte le decisioni mediche naturalmente
sono ben più di decisioni tecniche e
soprattutto nelle fasi finali della
nostra vita
sono quasi sicura che anche in un
necrologio forse di più che riguardava
mio padre qualcuno ha fatto scrivere se
n'è andato non ci ho fatto molto caso
non mi importava perché la cosa più
importante che mio padre è morto
cioè ha scelto ha potuto decidere ha
potuto scegliere
mio padre era sicuramente un
privilegiato lo era per tante ragioni
innanzitutto era medico e quindi era in
grado di capire era in grado di capire
quello che gli stavano dicendo era in
grado di capire quello che gli stava
succedendo e lo stavano a sentire anche
per questa ragione perché era un
interlocutore davvero tale
avevano assicurazione sanitaria su
questo tornerò perché naturalmente è un
privilegio e il nostro quello di avere
un servizio sanitario pubblico ma ci
sono degli aspetti che andrebbero
senz'altro migliorati e alcuni di questi
riguardano ancora di nuovo il come
avendo un'assicurazione sanitaria portò
scegliere per esempio la comunità di una
clinica in cui aveva una stanza da solo
in cui gli orari e gli appuntamenti
erano rispettati non rimandati in cui
chi lo andava a trovare non si doveva
sentire dopo pochi minuti
l'invito ad accomodarsi fuori perché
fuori fuori dalla stanza di qualcuno che
sta morendo non si sta comodi neanche
dentro naturalmente ma fuori
di certo non si sta comodi si poteva
perfino a dormire con lui e questo
senz'altro cambia cambia il morire di
una persona e cambia anche la vita di
chi sta vicino appunto a chi sta morendo
ma che cosa succede alle altre persone
che cosa succede alle scelte delle altre
persone come gestito il dolore parlare
di morte come vi dicevo potrebbe
funzionare o potrebbe meno essere un
tentativo di diminuire le disuguaglianze
di ridurre la differenza rispetto a chi
ci troviamo davanti
potremmo per esempio avere molta paura
di morire in ospedale
è giusto sapere che possiamo chiedere e
pretendere di morire in casa
potremmo essere molto spaventati del
dolore e quindi è giusto che sappiamo
che c'è ci sono dei modi per lenire il
dolore ed è un nostro diritto
ma spesso non lo sappiamo questa è la
mappa degli hospice che ci sono in
italia una mappa a cura della
federazione cure palliative onlus e
probabilmente molti di voi
anch'io prima di avere direttamente
occasione non sapevo quasi cosa fossero
gli hospice in pochi sanno anche i
medici spesso non sanno e non si sa che
si può essere appunto assistiti a
domicilio non si sa che in un hospice si
viene trattati e curate in modo diverso
da quello che succede in un ospedale
perché tutto è costruito almeno
nell'idea intorno alla persona che sta
per morire il tentativo è di dare a
queste persone una qualità migliore
il possibile più alta la prima
discriminazione ovviamente come è chiaro
è l'informazione
quindi sapere non solo sugli hospice ma
anche come accennavo prima ai farmaci
per il dolore alle cure palliative
all'assistenza domiciliare sapere che
tutto questo è il nostro diritto e
sapere che possiamo chiederlo non solo
questa discriminazione o questa
disuguaglianza sull'informazione è molto
più profonda invisibile riguarda come
noi riusciamo a capire quello che ci sta
quello che ci stanno dicendo anche se
siamo coscienziosi e abbiamo preso
informazioni e quello che si potrebbe
dire il mito del consenso informato come
facciamo a capire bene quello che ci
stanno dicendo
nel secondo rapporto sulle
disuguaglianze sociali in sanità nel
2014 si legge nel sistema sanitario i
punti maggiormente sensibili alle
disuguaglianze sociali sono i diversi
meccanismi di controllo della domanda
ticket esenzioni liste d'attese criteri
di priorità quelli di controllo
dell'offerta allocazione delle risorse
definizione dei livelli essenziali di
assistenza e la gestione
dell'appropriatezza qualità e continuità
delle procedure della condizione dei
percorsi assistenziali solo a leggere
queste righe si rimane un po confusi una
specie di buco nero delle informazioni
ma se vogliamo fare qualche altro
esempio
pensiamo al dibattito sulla mia che
forse avrete sentito nominare mia è un
acronimo che sta per nutrizione e
idratazione artificiali ed è venuto
fuori come elemento di cronaca molto
pesante quasi selvaggio quando si
discuteva di un disegno di legge di una
possibile legge sul testamento biologico
o direttive anticipate di trattamento in
quel caso c'è stato qualcuno è più di
qualcuno che ha detto non è un
trattamento medico la nutrizione
artificiale e quindi non potete
scegliere un esempio perfetto di una
premessa falsa e di un inferenza
completamente sballata
io ho qui due disegni che insomma non
richiedono commenti
non ho portato foto video perché possono
anche fare impressione ma se volete
potete cercare beli insomma ed è
evidente che un tubo e un buco nel
nostro corpo è qualcosa che insomma
qualcosa di molto invasivo e molto
invadente ed è anche molto difficile non
considerarlo un trattamento medici
medico
a parte il fatto che serve un consenso
informato e servono dei medici per fare
una cosa del genere ma di nuovo se non
lo sapete
potete trovarli facilmente nella
condizione in cui qualcuno deciderà al
posto vostro
e questo non riguarda solo un buco in
pancia riguarda qualunque altra tecnica
e qualunque altro trattamento medico
questo è per giorgio welby ve lo
ricorderete la tracheostomia o il
ventilatore meccanico qualunque tecnica
o trattamento su cui c'è bisogno di
avere la nostra volonta e la nostra
autorizzazione perché come vi dicevo
prima
ogni elemento ogni questione in medicina
non è solo una questione tecnica ma
riguarda la nostra volontà
la seconda disuguaglianza naturalmente
la legge cosa ci permette di fare la
legge qui in italia è vietato a dieta
tale tommasi è vietato il suicidio
assistito le date degli attivi
anticipate di trattamento non sono
riconosciute per fortuna non si è fatto
nessuno di quei disegni di legge in cui
c'era quell'orrore di cui vi dicevo
prima cioè la nutrizione come qualcosa
di non medico e quindi su cui non
avremmo potuto decidere però per esempio
è possibile chiedere la sedazione totale
questa potrebbe essere un'altra una
sottospecie di disuguaglianza potremmo
possiamo scegliere di essere
se dati in modo pesante totale quindi
perdere completamente la nostra
coscienza fino alla morte ma non
possiamo chiedere insomma di esercitare
fino in fondo la nostra
autodeterminazione
un esempio molto interessante di cui
dovremmo tener conto e quello
dell'olanda l'olanda è uno dei paesi che
è una legge più liberale ma al di là di
questo elemento
quello che è importante è interessante
sapere ciò che è successo prima della
legge
l'olanda ha fatto un indagine sul
fenomeno difficilmente fotografabile che
le tanasi è clandestina quindi andato a
vedere che cosa succedeva negli ospedali
e si sono resi conto che non solo
accadeva naturalmente quindi età sia
suicidio assistito accadevano ma spesso
accadevano senza il consenso del diretto
interessato cioè accadeva nel modo
peggiore possibile
come quel buco in pancia come altri
trattamenti insomma qualcun altro aveva
la parteza l'ardire di decidere per noi
e questo è veramente l'unica violazione
che non dobbiamo accettare o quella
principale
le direttive anticipate appunto
dovrebbero servire a questo dovrebbero
servire a garantire che quello che noi
vogliamo non vogliamo oggi possa valere
anche in un futuro
la terza disuguaglianza naturalmente
sono i soldi chi ha possibilità
economiche può andare in svizzera può
andare in un altro paese dove il diritto
è più garantito e dove c'è la
possibilità di avere appunto la morte
spesso c'è questo modo di dire la morte
con dignità
naturalmente la dignità e quella che noi
decidiamo è un valore soggettivo non è
che qualcuno ci viene a dire che la
nostra vita non è più dignitosa
questa e bethanie mainarda forse ve la
ricorderete è una donna alla quale è
stato diagnosticato un tumore cerebrale
che ha deciso di morire secondo appunto
la sua volontà o meglio di morire un po
prima non lasciando che la malattia la
condannasse a una sintomatologia
pesantissima come spesso nei casi dei
malati oncologici e soprattutto nel caso
nel suo caso di un tumore cerebrale è
andata dalla california l'oregon
l'oregon è un altro degli stati che
permette di morire con dignità e pochi
giorni prima di morire ha detto il mio
sogno che per tutti ci potrà essere
questa possibilità di scegliere c'è una
fondazione a suo nome che vedete che
cerca di portare avanti questo suo
desiderio
la quarta disuguaglianza è il servizio
la sanità accennavo prima la questione
del servizio sanitario pubblico
naturalmente non tutti in tutti noi in
tutti i paesi c'è un servizio sanitario
pubblico
ma ci sono altre altre facce meno
diciamo grossolane di disuguaglianza
come il fatto di capitale un ospedale in
un altro di capitare con un medico
oppure un altro di capitare con qualcuno
che conoscete
insomma una vera mappa di disuguaglianze
e una mappa di diverso accesso anche a
come trattato il dolore per esempio non
è raro che ancora oggi rispetto al
dolore alla richiesta di lenire il
dolore ci si guardi un po come dire ma
non siete abbastanza coraggiosi da da
affrontare il dolore una ben strana idea
di coraggio soprattutto per un dolore
quello delle malattie terminali che è un
dolore assolutamente inutile la quinta
la quinta disuguaglianza è l'attesa che
non è mortale aspettare non è mortale ma
è sicuramente snervante e lo è
soprattutto quando il nostro tempo è a
scadenza è quasi finito ci è stato detto
che stiamo per morire quindi figuratevi
che voglia uno può avere di aspettare
appuntamenti chemioterapie o servizi
anche qui i soldi naturalmente possono
fare la differenza tra un orario
rispettato e uno no
la sesta è che mestiere fate i medici
per esempio muoiono diversamente tendono
a pianificare ea rifiutare trattamenti
aggressivi inutili magari che
imporrebbero a noi o ai pazienti muoiono
in pace muoiono meglio la differenza è
spesso dovuto anche da quello che
possono capire come dicevo già prima e
questi dati questi che vi faccio vedere
solo brevemente perché la questione
della enorme differenza di questo ci ha
parlato giuseppe costa prima quindi è
solo un dato che si aggiunge
ulteriormente a le disuguaglianze che
qual è il nostro profilo socio culturale
incide moltissimo incide in generale
figuriamoci in una condizione terminale
la settima è tra persone coscienti e non
almeno in italia e in tutti gli altri
posti dove il testamento biologico lo
direttive anticipate non sono
forse la più crudele o la più difficile
da capire
ovvero se io sono cosciente posso
rifiutare qualunque trattamento
salvavita non salvavita posso decidere
se se rispetto a qualunque offerta
medica e approfitto anche per dire che
dovremmo liberarci di quello di
quell'espressione scema inutile che
accanimento terapeutico e dividerla in
due aspetti la nostra volontà che ripeto
è il cardine la bussola e ciò che è dal
punto di vista tecnico medico utile
quindi le domande che ci dobbiamo fare
voglio questo trattamento è questo
trattamento è utile o futile serve non
mi serve
liberiamoci di quest'espressione perché
se io non voglio qualcosa qualunque
trattamento anche poco invasivo è un
accanimento la forma di accanimento
terapeutico una violazione una violenza
vera e propria però questo accade se io
sono cosciente se posso difendermi se
non sono più cosciente cosa succede se
appunto il testamento biologico non mi
garantisce la continuità della mia
volontà succede che io perdo coscienza e
in genere un medico può decidere di fare
quello che fino a pochi minuti prima
avevo rifiutato
allora mi sento bamby si rianima mi si
mette qualche attrezzo per prolungare
una sopravvivenza che spesso è meramente
biologica c'era una puntata tante altre
ma insomma questa in particolare una
puntata di house in cui si chiamava
proprio rianimazione vietata in cui
house che però è un medico un ben strano
oltre che di fiction ma è un medico che
ingenera sempre ragione e questo è un po
difficile trovarlo nella realtà ma
insomma un certo punto lui viola la
richiesta di non rianimazione da parte
di un paziente nonostante il lieto fine
meraviglioso perché poi alla fine quel
paziente non solo sopravvive ma esce
meglio di come era entrato perché in
quell'occasione si scopre anche che
c'era stata una diagnosi sbagliata e
quindi in realtà lui entrano
incamminando esce quasi sano
beh house finisce in tribunale il motivo
è che per fortuna insomma in alcuni
sistemi quella è una serie di bombe
insomma e in alcuni sistemi la nostra
decisione quindi l'autodeterminazione è
considerata la cosa più importante
perfino
della vita stessa quindi se io ho detto
no qualcosa anche se poi mi fa meglio di
come avevo pensato
ciò non cambia il principio generale
l'ultima dichiarate l'ultima
disuguaglianza e come si parla di morte
come dire morte non saperlo fare se
avete avuto a che fare con medici
probabilmente avete avuto un'esperienza
diretta di questo la difficoltà di
parlare
aumenta naturalmente quando si tratta di
comunicare una diagnosi mortale o quando
si deve comunicare che i tentativi
magari viene a chi è ma terapia
sperimentale non hanno avuto successo
beh non è solo importante parlare e
saper parlare ma è anche importante
lasciar parlare il paziente lasciarci
parlare spiegare questa interessante
anche perché in genere si tende a
interrompere il paziente dopo 18 secondi
essere scoperto ci sono tanti studi in
merito uno famoso da lì è cominciato
insomma negli anni 80 in cui s'è capito
che sotto i 13 minuti di conversazione
il numero di denunce di malpractice era
molto alto con un numero che aumentava
di conversazione tra medico e paziente
dai 18 in su questo numero diminuirà
moltissimo ma non è solo importante
perché riduce i casi di denuncia o o
tenta di risolvere la cosiddetta
medicina difensiva ma naturalmente il
punto principale che riduce gli errori e
facilita una messa a punto di una
diagnosi e anche di un percorso
pagliativo quindi parlare è
importantissimo e l'empatia clinica è
uno strumento è uno strumento medico uno
strumento che ci permette di di rendere
una disciplina quella medica che è
diventata sempre più tecnicamente
funzionale insomma migliorata migliore
ma che umanamente spesso è ancora
carente e quindi lo strumento
dell'empatia clinica può provare a
riempire questo buco si può tra l'altro
insegnare e imparare in alcune
università statunitensi si insegna la
medicina narrativa e l'empatia clinica e
questo è uno dei tanti casi e in questo
caso
il tentativo è di rendere più umana una
condizione che è forse disumana ma non
per ragioni umane ma perché appunto ci
si ammala
in conclusione insomma se non possiamo
evitare o almeno non possiamo ancora
evitare dimora di morire possiamo almeno
provare a morire meglio e morire meglio
in genere significa morire come vogliamo
noi
[Musica]
[Applauso]